Salut bon dimanche, c'est le jour des explications
Je vous apprend quelque chose que vous allez pouvoir faire à d'autres personnes pour les bluffer !
Pour les mentaliser !
Et là je vais vous faire plaisir
parce qu'on va parler légèrement...très légèrement
mais un petit peu quand même
d'hypnose.
Je vous propose que vous fassiez un jeu hypnotique
sur une autre personne pour vous rendre compte vous déjà ce que c'est un peu l'hypnose
et pour mentaliser vos cobayes différemment que d'habitudes.
Je vous explique toute la procédure pas à pas
mais sachez que vous pouvez le faire sur vous même aussi en auto-hypnose
ça fonctionne avec un discours intérieur.
Expliquer à votre cobaye du jour que vous allez faire un jeu hypnotique
c'est à dire c'est pas vraiment de l'hypnose
c'est juste pour jouer
c'est quelque chose qui va être très positif pour lui !
Vous lui demander de se détendre un petit peu
et surtout de jouer le jeu mentalement.
S'il ne joue pas le jeu mentalement
alors ça ne fonctionnera pas, ça ne sera même pas la peine d'essayer.
Dans ce jeu hypnotique, tout le monde doit mettre un petit peu de bonne volonté
Vous lui demander de se détendre et de fixer un point au loin
Un point où il pourrait aller accrocher sa main
si jamais il se déplaçait
Il doit réellement visualiser ce point, complètement
il doit même imaginer dans sa tête comment il ferait pour s'y accrocher
ça peut être un montant de porte, ça peut être l'angle d'un mur, peu importe.
Une fois que c'est fait, vous lui demandez de fermer les yeux
la personne doit fermer les yeux.
Une fois que la personne a les yeux fermés
vous allez lui expliquer qu'au moment où elle va rouvrir les yeux
elle va s'imaginer réellement, mentalement
en se répétant "je vais m'accrocher"
qu'elle va réussir à étendre son bras pour s'accrocher mentalement
au point qu'elle a fixé.
Pour que ça fonctionne, vous pouvez lui expliquer
qu'il faut vraiment qu'elle mette sa main dans l'axe, dans l'angle de vue
pour avoir l'illusion, juste visuelle
qu'elle s'accroche réellement.
Dites lui de mettre réellement son bras en tension
et qu'elle s'imagine vraiment être accrochée là bas.
Elle ne doit fixer que son objectif
Donc son regard doit être axé uniquement au contact visuel de la main
et du point qu'elle a défini pour s'accrocher
et mentalement elle doit se répéter en boucle
"Je suis fermement accroché, rien ne peut plier mon bras..."
Elle doit donc se mettre dans un état de concentration
et votre rôle c'est de l'aider à ça
de la guider, de lui répéter en permanence que son bras est accroché
et que rien ne peut le plier, son bras est réellement accroché, rien ne peux le plier
Vous devez l'aider à se concentrer là dessus
et à ne pas détourner son attention ailleurs
Le focus du regard est très important, il ne doit jamais lâcher
ce point de contact comme ça
elle doit tout le temps le regarder, tout le temps, tout le temps, tout le temps...
jamais ailleurs.
Et au bout de une au deux minutes, voir même quelques secondes pour les plus efficaces
vous aller pouvoir vous amuser à essayer de plier son bras.
Ce sera pas possible.
Allez-y vraiment franchement, essayez de toutes vos forces de plier.
La personne plus vous pliez, plus elle doit se convaincre qu'elle est accrochée là-bas
qu'elle est physiquement accrochée sans lâcher le point de vue
ce qui va bloquer ses muscles plus fermement que ce qu'elle arriverait à faire consciemment.
Si vous êtes plusieurs, vous pouvez demander à des amis de vous aider à plier le bras de la personne
vous allez voir une résistance hors normes
par rapport à ce qu'elle pourrait faire habituellement.
Comme je vous le disais au tout départ
vous pouvez le faire aussi sur vous-même
en vous mettant dans cet état de concentration et de focus
en vous répétant mentalement que vous êtes réellement accroché
et là vous demander à d'autres personnes
d'essayer de plier votre bras
ce sera pas possible.
J'espère sincèrement que ce petit tour du dimanche
un petit peu différent de d'habitude
vous aura plu.
Vous le savez, sur la chaîne c'est step by step
donc je vous réserve encore pas mal de surprises.
N'oubliez pas que j'ai organisé une FAQ
pour fêter les 30 000 abonnés
c'est la FAQ que je ferai jeudi
donc posez moi vos questions jusqu'à mercredi soir sur twitter
Avec le hashtag #mentalisme30000
Ça fait un peu super marché discount, mais le hashtag me faisait rire
et j'ai vu qu'il y en à qui avait déjà posé leurs questions, c'est parfait.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, alors dans ces cas là
vous n'entendez que le son de ma voix
et vous vous focalisez sur un magnifique et tétanisant
pouce en l'air !
N'hésitez pas à mettre en petit commentaire
vous le savez en ce moment je répond un petit peu moins que d'habitude
mais je les lis toujours tous, comme vous pouvez le constater
quand vous me posez une question très importante
là je prends quelques secondes pour le faire.
Donc je suis toujours présent
je suis en train de préparer les vidéos là pour cet été
ça me prend énormément de temps.
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner avant de partir
puisque le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
depuis le premier janvier, donc rendez-vous demain à 17h !
Ciao